let's get into the four major signs of
envy
um the first one is micro expressions
which is uh known as dagger eyes they're
hard to spot because they only last for
a few seconds
but i guarantee you i mean i'm a little
bit older than
most of you guys watching me if you're
under me under my agenda i mean i'm
close to 47 48 now but you're gonna find
out
you know when you look around in life
that there's times where
at certain events where you might have
been doing something great maybe you had
a success in your business somebody will
look at you you know kind of like at the
corner of their eyes and they and they
you know they kind of glare at you they
have that you know that glint of like
envy and like anger and
like it's it's not easy to
decipher until you've seen it it's hard
to explain
um until you've seen it and it's genuine
you're gonna know what it is
uh but these micro ex but these micro
expressions do pop
up so you have to be attentive to them
so that's the first sign the second sign
which is a little more obvious and this
is one that
this is the one that sent chills up my
spine when i when i heard them
you know describe it in the audio book
it's called poisonous praise
and what that is is a disparaging
comment cushioned as praise
for example when you successfully finish
a project they'll comment on how much
money you will make
rather than praise your hard work
completing the project let me say that
again
poisonous praise is a disparaging
comment cushioned as praise
for example when you successfully finish
a project they will comment about how
much money you will make rather than
praise your hard work
i can i can give you one example
actually i can give you several examples
and i'm going to tie them you know back
a decade into my debt business because
uh between
2000 and i think 2007 and 2010 for those
three years
um we probably got
more awards in those three years in the
business for hyper growth for culture
for all for all kinds of business
accolades i mean
we were in profit magazine several times
uh i was featured on the front page of
the toronto star i mean if you guys
google my uh full name plus a toronto
star um you know you'll see the article
but
um you know the biggest newspaper in in
canada featured me in my business on the
front page so
word got out about you know the
successes that i had had in the
businesses
and the poisonous praise started to come
frequent and often and it and it sounded
a lot like
uh oh yeah you know i can imagine how
much money you you know that
you must be making not oh really you
know you've saved over 100 million
dollars worth of credit card debt and
you've gotten
you know thousands of people out of debt
and back on their financial fee so they
so they could avoid bankruptcy and
you know like the standard sort of
praise that people that aren't envious
of you would give
instead what they're giving you is oh
you know i can imagine how much money
you must be making off this sort of
thing and how rich you must be now and
blah blah blah sort of thing
um i also heard it recently too you know
if i was um
for example during during covert you
know for the last year
whenever somebody would ask uh you know
what i was doing at the bank
or um there was another guy that ran
like this uh
consulting firm that had tried to try to
you know get into my business and do
some work for us and
you know the standard lyrics were oh you
know covet must really be driving your
uh business right up and you
you know you guys must be making a ton
of money you know the remember the
banker said it a couple times there's a
couple of different bankers that had to
deal with that were
talking you know specifically about how
much money you must be making rather
than praising you for what you're
actually doing to get people out of debt
that's the way that i've always looked
at that business was we actually
unfuck people's lives and get them out
of debt in a fashion that's better and
quicker
than the conventional methods that are
available to them
but the poisonous praise comes from
those that envy you so you have to be
aware of that keep an eye open you know
keep an ear
open for it too um backbiting
envious people enjoy talking about the
negative aspects up so
this is the third one backbiting is
envious people that enjoy talking about
the negative aspects of a person's
character
whether it's real or imagined
this is more of a female sort of centric
behavior
but i see a lot of guys do this too
it's kind of gossipy and what they'll do
is they'll go looking for anything that
can support
their narrative you know they want to
try to discredit you
um you know up up towards the top when i
open this you know i was talking about
how
these people are so dangerous because
they really seek to do you harm
they don't want to operate at your level
they want to bring you down to their
level
right so the backbiting is
the third one let's talk about the last
one which is see-sawing which is the
fourth
sign of envy and it's positively
negative
uh actions meaning they're going to heap
on praise then harsh criticisms
then they're gonna warm up you you know
warm you up again and then they're gonna
keep
repeating the cycle i think out of all
of those
the most obvious one that you need to be
aware of is poisonous praise
oh that's great you must be making a ton
of money oh that's great
you know when are you going to buy us
all you know whatever
you know sort of thing and you'll get
this from
people very very close to you maybe even
family members maybe even friends
um it's you know it's bizarre because it
was it was totally over my head for many
many years
until it was defined as poisonous praise
and how it's a disparaging comment
uh cushioned as praise when in fact it's
it's really just like you know [ __ ]
on you in an underhanded way
you